quand j'étais jeune j'ai intégré l'armée
quand j'ai quitté la marine royale j'ai
rencontré un certain quand je dois
ses clients voulaient faire tuer des
gens
des mauvaises personnes des meurtriers
les violeurs des fonctionnaires
corrompus
c'est là que j'interviens
[Applaudissements]
la voilà tu m'as manqué
c'est pas vrai qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est rien je vais bien à chaque fois
que tu reviens tu as des bleus des
coupures et maintenant ça là j'ai reçu
une nouvelle mission ça y est j'ai eu ma
dose j'étais pas si simple il y a six
contre différents et chacun de ces
contrats te rapportera un million de
dollars je t'écoute ce sont des
assassins Morgan comme toi
et ils ont été engagés pour me tuer et
pour s'entretuer en fait Morgan ils
essaieront de te tuer
que tu acceptes le boulot non c'est un
simple jeu et si tu veux vivre tu vas
devoir participer
je peux rien promettre
ils vont venir et maintenant je dois me
battre pour te protéger quel que soit
tes ennuis il faut y mettre un terme tu
te dis que tu es quelqu'un de bien
Morgan tu seras la prochaine d'abord tu
vas souffrir
quelqu'un nous manque les uns contre les
autres à un moment il faut assumer les
conséquences de ses actes